you really can't tell the meaning of
someone's life till the very end it's
for the same reason right is that how
all the pieces fit together in the story
or in the life is not necessarily
determined until the final moment and I
think that's part of the reason to why
among Catholics for example and
Christians in general there's an idea
that salvation can always be attained
right right up to the last moment no
matter what your life was like and you
think well that's a pretty cheap trick
because you can run around doing
terrible things your whole life but as
long as you get it together the last
second then you're scot-free but if you
think about it in terms of a story then
you can understand how that could
conceivably be the case and it's for
this reason of course that this lecture
in particular makes me nervous more than
any of the other ones I do because I've
been telling you a story that's
basically 40 hours long right in its
spoken form and then who knows how long
in its written form and it's it's
complicated to pull it together properly
and that's partly because as far as I've
been concerned we've been talking about
issues in psychology that are more
difficult than any other first of all
conceptually even from a
neuropsychological perspective because
I've been offering you a model the way
the brain process is the environment
that I think is really novel and I think
it reflects the current state of
neuroscience and but more than that
there's the problem that we've been
dealing with issues all the way along of
life and death and of war and
destruction and of the possibility for a
clear-headed optimism right a
possibility which as we've discussed
more or less escaped Tolstoy say for
most of his life right because when
Tolstoy woke up from his delusions he
looked at the world and he said well
clearly it's such a terrible place that
as if you're not looking at it through
the veils of illusion there's no way
that you can do anything but stand in
opposition to it once you understand its
basic structure right suffering and
innocent suffering and complete
vulnerability and the whole existential
mess that makes up life now it turns out
that Tolstoy overcame his
rationally induced cynicism in a kind of
mystical way he had a dream that he was
suspended from some transcendent space
by a belt around the middle of his waist
which hung him over a pit of chaos and
in that image he found comfort and fair
enough it's a powerful image but it's
not well delineated right and it worked
well for Tolstoy and you can see that
the image has power but you can't you
can't grab it with your rational mind
you can't take it into pieces and
analyze it as an argument and that's
what we do if we're intellectuals right
we try to understand the detailed
structure of something and I think the
detailed structure of what Tolstoy
apprehended as optimistic is actually
comprehensible and we've been working
towards that and circling around the
entire course of this lecture series but
I found with this material that with
each circling around the target it gets
clearer and clearer it's a funny thing
it's like you're looking at something
that's too complicated to see all at
once so you have to look at it from
multiple different perspectives and
again and again and each time you look
at it it becomes clearer and clearer and
that's still the case for me when I go
through this material every time I go
through it I think only how that piece
fits there and that piece fits there and
that's how that makes sense and oh
that's a lot more remarkable than I
thought it was to begin with and so on
and it seems fundamentally and
exhaustible and of course that's what
you'd expect from deep deep stories
right stories that have been around for
thousands and thousands of years
wouldn't have been around for thousands
and thousands of years unless they were
in some sense inexhaustible and we've
talked about some of the processes that
might contribute to that
inexhaustibility so at the beginning of
the lecture series I told you to
consider the assumption that there was
more than one way of looking at the
world right there was the standard
materialist sort of scientific viewpoint
which was that the world was made up of
objects independently existent us among
them the objects had no intrinsic value
one way or another and the issue of
meaning per se wasn't included in that
account and then I said well wait
there's another way
looking at the world that we spent just
as much time developing that we utilize
even more and that's a narrative that's
the narrative way of looking at the
world to consider the nature of
experience rather than the nature of
objects as real to consider your
experience as real even though it
includes things that can't be easily and
tangibly identified things like emotions
which of course you find compelling
sometimes even beyond your will things
like motivational states fantasies
ideals all the things that compel your
behavior and give you some sense that
there's a direction to life and people
who study emotion and perception have
come to understand that the act of
transforming the world into something
simply made out of objects is incredibly
difficult it's so difficult that we
haven't been able to design machines
that can do it at all it turns out also
that when we look at the world we're not
just looking at it with our visual
systems but we're looking at it with our
motor output systems and our emotion so
that when you look at something like a
chair which just stands there for you
like an object it turns out that the
mechanical systems the motor systems
that you would use to use the chair to
sit on it are activated during the
active perception it also turns out
sometimes that when you look at
something especially if it's something
you don't understand and that it's and
that scares you you actually react to it
conceptualize it with your body and with
your emotions before you have any idea
what it is from the perspective of an
object
when you look at the world and when you
think about the world you have to do it
from a motivation a motivated
perspective and an emotionally ridden
perspective you can't even see the world
without being gripped by your motivation
and emotional states and so the idea
that rationality or perception is
somehow separate from or superordinate
to perception and emotion is just wrong
we understand now that you can't even
think without being motivated you can't
see the world without being motivated
and that means you always look at the
world through a kind of lens and the
lens is a narrowing lens and it has to
be because the world is so complicated
you can't see it all at once you're only
seeing tiny slices of it in time and
tiny slices of it in space and and even
then you have to narrow it to only those
things that are relevant to you at that
moment and we don't know exactly how you
do that we know that it takes years and
years of perceptual work in infancy say
so that you managed to build up an
object conception of the world that's
probably all you're doing in the first
two or three years of life and you're
doing it constantly and it's just as
complicated as learning language say or
even more complicated most of its
invisible and we don't know how children
do that and by the time they can talk
they've already done it so they can't
even tell us what they're doing it takes
a long time to build up an object world
when you look at the world when you go
from point A to point B even when you're
doing something as simple as looking for
food in in the kitchen you ignore
everything about the world that isn't
relevant to making yourself a peanut
butter sandwich and you focus in on
those few things that are the
refrigerator the food the knives the
cutlery and so on and everything else is
screened out and you can't help but look
at the world through that kind of lens
and the lens has changed you can be in
different motivational states and they
can change because of internal
transformations you're not hungry you're
thirsty or you're not thirsty you're
interested in someone or somebody's
telling you a story and then you adopt
their motivational framework and you can
see the world through their eyes and now
we know the neural machinery for that
and we already talked about that so we
can toss back and forth these
motivational reims frames of reference
and that gives us
insight into someone else's world you
can look at the world endless numbers of
ways and what you're trying to do is out
of its infinite richness so to speak is
to pull out parts of it that are useful
for you while you're moving from point A
to point B and this can be a chair if
you want to sit down but if you want to
take the light bulb out of the ceiling
then it's then it's a stool or a table
and whether or not it's a chair or a
stool or a table depends just as much on
what you're doing as it does on what it
is and I think that's part of the reason
why human beings can be so infinitely
creative right for us the world isn't
fixed we never know what it's going to
bring forth so a hundred years ago if
someone would have said well you could
build a machine on a wafer a centimeter
square out of sand and if you have
enough of those machines then everyone
in the world can be connected and
everyone in the world can have an
infinite library of verbal material
right that's impossible but it's not
impossible it turns out that silica has
those properties and we can build
unbelievably powerful machines out of
nothing and so then that kind of makes
you think about just what this nothing
that we're building things out of is
right because it seems to be able to
reveal a constant array of properties
properties that are essentially
unlimited and its capacity to reveal
those properties seems to depend as much
on our ability to interact with it
whatever that is as it does on whatever
the stuff is and we know even from a
strict object perception of the world
that the stuff that things are made of
is a lot more complicated than we had
originally presumed even as materialists
because materialists realists their
philosophy only holds down to about the
subatomic level of analysis a
deterministic worldview below the
subatomic level of analysis there's
nothing deterministic at all and the
stuff that things are made of is so
mysterious that we can't even we can't
grasp but we can't comprehend it so it
turns out that rather than the story
world be being dependent on the object
world it might
the other way around the object world is
dependent on the story world and that
implies at least to some degree that the
story world is actually more real
whatever that means
then I told you that well the real
problem of life isn't so much what do
you do when you're around things that
you understand the real problem of life
is what do you do when you encounter
something you can't conceptualize and I
think a good recent example of that was
the bombing of the World Trade Towers
which people were compelled to watch
over and over and over and over and if
you ask someone well what is it that
you're watching they would say while I'm
watching the World Trade Towers fall
down but then you might say well why are
you watching it over and over and they
would say something like well I can't
believe it I can't believe it's
happening and what does that mean it
means something like whatever it is
that's happening here whatever is being
blown apart exceeds my ability to model
and as a consequence I have to expose
myself to it again and again and again
and again to try to understand what's
falling what's falling exactly is it
just is it just the towers is it 20,000
people is it the financial system of the
u.s. is it the stability of the Western
world is at the beginning of World War 3
or as the former CIA director just
mentioned in the US the beginning of
World War 4 what is it exactly that
you're looking at when something happens
that you don't understand
and then you say well how do you react
to that and it turns out that you react
mostly with your body not with your mind
not with your perceptual systems not
with your thoughts but with your
emotions and your body and that means
you sweat and you panic and you feel
depressed and you feel hurt and you feel
ashamed and you're prepared for a
catastrophe which is stress and all
that's basically non-cognitive and what
that kind of means is that when you
encounter something you don't understand
the first manner in which you conceive
of it is embodied emotional physical way
before you develop up an object
representation or cognitive
representation you may now never get it
like an event like that or a worse event
can throw someone into a tailspin that's
so extreme that they never get out of it
so you see for example sometimes and
this is more true among elderly people
if their spouse dies the probability
that they'll die in the next year say
from a heart attack or something like
that increases substantially why is that
it's because their conceptual frame was
so dependent on the existence of their
spouse say someone they've lived with
for 25 years that the anxiety and
uncertainty caused by their anomalous
disappearance their death is so extreme
that it sends their body into a
physiological state that's basically
unbearable and that does them in and
when you start to understand what having
your preconceptions rattled really means
then you also start to understand why
people are so motivated to protect their
ideological territory right because
ideological territory that's how you see
the world that's your story and you
can't have your fundaments rattled all
the time because it throws everything
into chaos and that puts you in this
terrible panicky cortisol ridden
stressful state that's really hard on
you physically so we know for example
that if you're in a state where you're
chronically exposed to threat or
punishment which is the case in
depression say you produce a lot of
cortisol which is a stress hormone and
cortisol is toxic so the more of it you
produce the more you kill off your
hippocampal cells and you really need
them because they are key to memory you
do in your immunological system there's
also
of negative side-effects of cortisol
poisoning increased incidence of
cardiovascular disease heightened rate
of cancer plus it's just no fun right
it's the worst thing that can possibly
happen to you
essentially if something unknown happens
to you and blows your frame of reference
right knocks you for a loop sends you to
the underworld however you want to
construe it that's really going to upset
your bandwagon and throw you into a
state that you do virtually anything to
avoid but by the same token there is a
possibility that inside that chaotic
mess there's something you really need
and what's the logic there well the
logic is something like this when you
look at the world you only see a
fragment of it and that's good because
it's pretty overwhelming and a fragments
generally more than enough but all the
information that you've ever gathered in
your entire life to build yourself out
of and to make your life stable has come
as a consequence of your ability to
explore what you don't understand and
that's an unlimited capacity right no
matter how much you explore and how much
information you gather there's always
the possibility that there's way more
information out there and that means if
you have a problem and you see that it's
a problem even though that's frightening
it's also a gateway into a domain of
possibility and the possibility is this
richly informative background that could
in principle provide you with any answer
you need way and then you can fake one
more thing for the old gods Mars say the
God of War Venus the God of love they're
all internalized for us right we know
that anger is a psychological state love
is a psychological state but if we look
at our great religious traditions
Christianity say or Buddhism just to
take two as an example we still have
this notion that what these figures
represent is something external well you
might say how primitive right just as
primitive as the idea that the God of
War is something external is the idea
that this sort of figure is supposed to
be something external it's supposed to
be something embodied right it's a story
about the nature of individual moral
responsibility
so the idea is something like this well
reality itself the existence of things
seems to depend on the existence of a
finite observer so that we can see
things from a perspective if you don't
see things from a perspective everything
is the same
there's nothing delineated but if
there's going to be delineated things it
small things insufficient things and
they're going to be aware they're going
to be vulnerable as a part of their
limitation so you say well limitation is
a precondition for being and that means
suffering is part and parcel of being
Dostoevsky said clearly look I'll give
you all the cake you want you got a big
house you got nothing to do but watch TV
right and propagate the species are you
happy and Dostoevsky says well no why
well because human beings are really
fundamentally ungrateful and insane so
if you give them some little comfortable
niche to occupy themselves with so they
don't have anything to worry about the
first thing they're going to do just
like Adam and Eve basically are just
like Gautama Buddha they're going to run
around looking for the Apple looking for
the snake looking for the trouble to
smash the frame into bits no matter how
comfortable it is just so they can get
access to little chaos and have some fun
and so then you think well maybe it's
more like the purpose of life isn't to
avoid chaos because we like chaos it's
entertaining right it keeps us alert and
awake and it gives us something to do
that really has no end and so maybe the
answer is something more like well
forget the frame of reference and forget
the chaos but hit the balance right
between the two right so that you got
one foot where it's reasonably
comfortable and you've got one foot out
there where it's kind of exciting and
dangerous and that's perfect and then
you think the state you want to attain
that makes you resistant to even the
greatest anomalies anomalies of death
say or vulnerability or mortality is
exactly that's that position right now
it's straight between the forces of
chaos and the forces of order or
between yin and yang and how do you know
you're there because that's what it
really boils down to how do you know
that you're there and then you think
okay
simple you watch with your eyes open
just like Solzhenitsyn watch do you
think I don't know everything so let's
see what I do know no preconceptions I'm
not going to shield myself from the
truth with some second-rate frame of
reference we don't believe in those
anyways because they're always
fragmental I'm just going to watch so
when am I not miserable and then you
think well I'm not miserable when I'm
interested in things something I get
interested in something I don't exactly
know why I get interested in it it
catches me what are the what's the
phenomenology of being caught I'm not
self-conscious when I'm engaged in
something I'm more like a child which is
why children have intimations of
immortality I'm engaged in this process
I don't think about myself so I'm not
self-conscious I lose my sense of
temporality because it seems like I can
do whatever it is that I'm doing thing
that I enjoy for hours and the time
flies by and I'm not even really aware
of the surrounding world and none of my
existential concerns are paramount at
that time every need is suppressed by my
engagement in the activity and then you
say to yourself well yeah fine that only
happens like you know ten minutes every
three days or something when I'm being
particularly miserable but you might say
well the fact that it happens at all is
probably worth paying attention to I
mean if you believe that your experience
is real like real the fact that you can
get into a state like that at all is
worth paying attention to and so then
you might say well that's that's where
your sense of ethics really starts to
arise is what makes you interested well
it might be just as cracked and gun and
peculiar as something you could possibly
imagine right your parents are against
it your friends are against it even
you're against it when you're thinking
clearly but there's still this reality
that something compels you and then you
think well can you trust it and I think
well that's a tough question
because I read a long time for a long
time I read the counts of serial killers
because I was really interested in what
motivated them right and they're an
interesting breed in many ways which is
why there's such a popular fascination
with them and so then you think about a
story like that you think geez
maybe you can't trust your interest
right maybe it'll take you somewhere you
don't want to go like seriously where
you don't want to go how do you know
that if you really let yourself be who
you could be that you'd end up somewhere
good and so then you come to the second
part of the story which is something
like this let's say that you're a very
very very finely tuned biological
machine right look into a computer and
then you say okay you take a computer
and you feed it false information what
do you get out false information right
well you've stuck with this computer
it's very complicated
you kind of reside in it in some manner
you don't understand
and yet you're prone upon occasions
either to deny it information altogether
when you walk away from something you
know you shouldn't walk away from or
defeat it bad information and so then
what if it what if this was the case
what if it was the case that the systems
that orient you with regards to your
interest can become pathologized by any
relationship you have with yourself
that's predicated on bad faith and so
then you think well that's why there's
an ethical aspect to this redemptive
process like a real strenuous and strict
ethical aspect it goes something like
this there are things that you can do
find yourself engaged with the world at
such a level that your existential
concerns could disappear and we can even
understand that biochemically to some
degree because if you're really
interested in something you get a
dopamine release an exploratory dopamine
release that's great I mean that's
associated with positive effect with
confidence with increased immunological
functioning with better memory
functioning with learning everything you
want it's all so potently anti-anxiety
and analgesic which means that if you're
really pursuing something that's
compelling to you you're much more
resistant biochemically to punishment
disappointment depression pain threat
etc and it's not because you're blind
it's not because you're blind it's
because your nervous system is optimally
tuned to make you maximally resistant
and so then you might think if you were
optimally tuned how resistant would you
be it
no right because it's a spiral that
never stops moving uphill we don't know
what the upper end is I mean we have
exemplars that might indicate what that
upper end could be but we don't actually
know so then you think okay well here's
the here's the rule say it's something
like this if you look at the world from
this perspective which is something you
have to decide if you're you know you
find compelling and reasonable the rule
is this you're always going to run into
anomaly right and uh normally is always
going to look to look to you like like
this and it's no bloody wonder you want
to run away from that I mean in some
ways your whole body's telling you watch
out and for good reason because it's no
joke
but then there's more to the story
because the anomalous thing that's
everything you don't know and you might
say well you're going out with someone
you want to have a long-term
relationship they betray you how could
it be any good in that because that's
certainly what you're going to ask when
you first encounter the unexpected
information but then you might think
could be that I'm a little too naive for
my own good right people pull me in a
little more than they should or I'm not
sufficiently careful when I enter into
intimate relationships with people or
don't treat people right or I don't have
a good conceptualization of myself or
I'm chasing after the wrong person well
that's all going to be very annoying to
learn but if you don't learn it you're
going to be in big trouble so maybe the
best thing to do when an anomaly of that
sort hits you is to think okay yeah it's
a dragon no doubt it will eat me but if
I don't let it eat me then they'll just
be another one waiting around the corner
and it'll probably be a little bit
bigger and if I get eaten by enough of
them I'm not really going to want to be
around much and maybe I'm not going to
be willing to help other people be
around much either doesn't seem like a
very good alternative to me
back in 1957 some new Gnostic writings
were discovered in a and a cave they
were discovered by these two Arab guys
who went out to kill the man who killed
their father they took him out into this
cave and they killed him and when they
were burying him they found these
amphora full of papers and papyrus and
they took them home and their mother
used a bunch of them - like cooking
fires with and one day one of their
friends who was an antiquities dealer
showed up and he said you know you
shouldn't be burning those those are
about 1500 years old and they look like
very early Gnostic Gospels and the
Gnostics were this branch of
Christianity that was pretty violently
suppressed by the emergence of Orthodox
Christianity and the Gnostics believed
that faith was a good thing but
knowledge was all right - and they wrote
gospel accounts say of Christ's life
that were knowledge predicated as much
as revelation predicated say and this is
one of the quotes from one of those
Gospels the Gospel of Thomas which is
actually one that the only one that got
out Carl Jung got ahold of interestingly
enough and this is one of the quotes and
I really like this this is a non
canonical saying of Christ and the
saying is if you bring forth what is
within you what you bring forth will
save you if you do not bring forth what
is within you what you do not bring
forth will destroy you and I think
that's a pretty good line to close off
the class so thank you for attending
you